this video is made possible by curiosity
stream and nebula there's another
full-length companion video about the
rights you definitely want to exercise
which you can access by signing up for
the curiosity stream nebula bundle for
less than 15 a year at the link below
so it turns out that americans the most
free people in the entire world
asterisks have a lot of lesser known
rights and freedoms as americans there
is a deep well of obscure rights across
these united states that are just
sitting on shelves gathering dust so
let's talk about more of the legal
rights that you have but probably don't
want in any way shape or form but quick
legal disclaimer as always this
information is for educational
entertainment purposes only and does not
cost you legal advice exercising some of
the rights discussed in this video could
result in bodily harm drawn out
litigation being shunned by one's peers
just because you can legally do
something doesn't mean you should
restrictions may apply and please
consult with your doctor and your
attorney who isn't made before
attempting any of these freedoms okay
with that out of the way let's get
started
and so we start with the americanist of
american freedoms the right to own
flamethrowers and of course other
extremely deadly weapons when
politicians and judges decide the
meaning of the second amendment it's
often the context of determining what
types of weapons should or should not be
in the hands of a civilian population
that was the line pre-president joe
biden took in a 2019 interview with
anderson cooper while arguing in favor
of an assault weapons ban look the
second amendment doesn't say you can't
restrict the kinds of weapons people can
own
you can't buy a bazooka you can't have a
flamethrower well actually mr president
it turns out that you can own a
flamethrower you also can own a bazooka
with some restrictions in fact there are
a variety of high-powered and deadly
weapons you can legally own in the
united states under the national
firearms act of 1934 as revised by the
gun control act of 1968 and the omnibus
crime control and safe streets act of
1968 individuals can legally acquire
sawed-off shotguns any automatic weapons
like machine guns made before 1986 and
destructive devices like grenades
mortars and yes even bazookas but i'm
sorry to tell you that these weapons
commonly known as title ii weapons or
nfa firearms can only be acquired after
passing a background check paying a 200
transfer tax registering the weapon with
the atf and obtaining the approval of
the attorney general though a few states
like delaware new york and california
prohibit ownership of all of certain
types of title ii weapons but most
states allow for the legal ownership if
the owner has complied with federal
registration and taxation requirements
oh and fyi if you decide to shoot a
missile in south carolina you can do it
as long as you get a permit first fun
fact flamethrowers are an entirely
different animal though believe it or
not there is no federal law governing
the private use of flamethrowers also
known as extended reach torches in fact
only two states in the country have any
restrictions on flamethrowers at all
maryland and california maryland flat
out bans the device while california
only allows you to obtain one if you get
a permit from the state fire marshal and
as you may know elon musk has even
gotten into the flamethrower game by
selling his own propane-powered not a
flamethrower device named to head off
issues with customs officials however
people who have tried to take his
product overseas have often found that
customs officials disagree that this
device is not a flamethrower landing
these people in legal trouble abroad and
like many other topics discussed in this
video you may be asking how on earth is
this possibly legal after all flame
throwers were historically a weapon of
war especially during world war ii a
flame-throwing tank stalks the mass
funeral fire there is no eulogy and no
mourning but contrary to their
portrayals in movies and video games
flamethrowers are classified as tools
not weapons and as tools flamethrowers
actually have a wide variety of
legitimate uses outside of your garden
variety cartoon super villainy flame
throwers can be used to clear vegetation
quickly melt snow from your driveway can
be used to quickly sanitize stadium
seats in what's known as flame polishing
they're great for cooking steaks and
don't tell anyone but they work really
well in training dogs and cats though
it only works once
now despite all of these completely
legitimate uses state and federal
lawmakers from new york have tried to
ban the device in response to musk's not
a flamethrower stunt new york state
lawmakers introduced a bill to outlaw
flamethrowers though the bill remains
stalled and in 2015 2018 and 2020 new
york congressman eliot engel sought to
outlaw the possession or transfer of
flamethrowers via the flamethrowers
question mark really question mark act
yes that is actually the name of the
bill that he introduced the bill never
made it out of committee and congressman
engel left congress in 2021 after losing
a primary challenge for reasons
completely unrelated to flamethrowers
but that takes us to your right to
secretly record your conversations with
third parties that may or may not be
related to conversations about
flamethrowers a common trope in film and
tv involves characters secretly
recording their own conversations to
catch a third party admitting to
criminal activity it's my word against
yours
200 bucks a day fluff 365 days a year
since i was 12. actually it's your word
against yours so therein lies the
question can you actually do that well
to give everyone's favorite answer
it totally depends mostly depends on
whether you're violating any federal or
state wiretapping laws federal law
permits the recording of any phone call
electronic communication or in-person
conversation including video that
captures audio with the consent of one
of the parties to the conversation also
known as a one-party consent law so
under a one-party consent law you may
record any conversation so long as you
are a party to that conversation you are
that one party that can consent if you
are not a party to the communication
then at least one person must give you
consent to the recording or you may have
committed the you know the crime of
eavesdropping now 38 states plus the
district of columbia have adopted a
one-party consent law the remaining
states though have a two-party consent
law now two-party consent is a bit of a
misnomer because you first have to get
consent to every party to that
conversation so if there are three
parties that conversation you have to
get consent from all three and as a
threshold matter state and federal
wiretapping laws only protect
conversations when the speaker has a
reasonable expectation of privacy for
the conversation so for example even
though these things take place in public
people do have a reasonable expectation
of privacy in a public bathroom stall or
locker room and both audio and video
recordings and such a place would likely
violate state and federal law without
the subject's consent in contrast though
a person bragging at a private party
about cheating with a friend in a
business deal probably couldn't claim a
wiretap violation even if this
conversation was recorded without
consent in addition federal law along
with 17 one-party consent states
prohibits the recording of conversations
when done with criminal or tortious
intent as an example secretly recording
a conversation to use as blackmail would
probably not be protected in contrast
though a federal appeals court held that
a son who used his phone to secretly
record a conversation about his dying
mother's will could not be federally
prosecuted for wiretapping because the
sun lacked tortious or criminal intent
independent of the recording oh and
here's one more thing to consider if
your secretly recorded phone call takes
place between two different states you'd
better ensure that both states are
one-party consent jurisdictions or you
could find yourself in legal trouble
that's what happened to linda tripp back
in the 1990s government employee linda
tripp secretly recorded her confidential
phone calls with former white house
intern monik lewinsky wherein miss
lewinsky provided salacious details
about her intimate relationship with
then president bill clinton now these
tapes became a public sensation upon
their release and the fallout from the
scandal resulted in president clinton's
impeachment where of course he was
acquitted by the senate now here's where
linda tripp found herself the target for
prosecution though dc is a one-party
recording jurisdiction linda tripp
recorded her calls from maryland which
requires all parties to consent in
january 1998 miss tripp turned over the
tapes to independent council's kenneth
starr in exchange for immunity however
maryland prosecutors indicted miss tripp
on state wiretapping charges anyway
arguing that federal immunity did not
extend to state violations but before
that trial the judge ruled that miss
lewinsky whose testimony the state
needed to prove tripp broke the law
would be barred from testifying and
without their star witness the state
dropped all charges in may of 2000. so
your mileage may vary and that takes us
to one of my favorite american rights of
all time that is the right to steal
someone's house yes that is actually a
thing
one of the most important rights that
come with being a homeowner is the right
to keep unwanted intruders off your
property in fact a person that knowingly
enters your property without permission
has committed a trespass and is subject
to immediate arrest but here's an
interesting wrinkle if you commit
trespass for a day you go to jail but if
you openly trespass for years well
congratulations you now own that land
and any buildings that are on top of it
that's right you can actually crime your
way into becoming a property owner in
certain circumstances but fair warning
this is not an advisable or easy way to
earn title to property as it usually
takes decades of trespass and fulfilling
other state-specific requirements
for that property to actually change
ownership alright so for purely
informational purposes here is how a
would-be house thief could actually do
this under a doctrine that's called
adverse possession a trespasser who
continuously possesses or occupies real
property for a certain length of time
can actually acquire legal ownership to
the property that they're illegally
occupying to invoke adverse possessions
sufficient to get ownership the
trespasser's occupation on the land must
meet certain requirements it must be
hostile it must be done without
permission of the owner must be actual
so they have to be physically present
has to be open and notorious the act of
trespassing can't be secret and must be
obvious to onlookers and the trespasser
must be in possession of the property
for an uninterrupted period of time as
prescribed by whatever statute we're in
the time period for vesting varies by
state ranging from 5 to 30 years but
most commonly 10 to 20 years is required
of you know actual trespassing some
states require payment of property taxes
during the occupation period others
mandate physical improvements to the
land and some states even require the
trespasser to produce some kind of
document or deed relating to the
ownership of the property even if the
document itself is inaccurate or carries
no legal weight now you might be asking
why in the world would every state give
people the right to legally steal land
albeit very very slowly well the concept
of adverse possession actually dates
back to 6th century roman law adverse
possession was designed to encourage
landowners to make beneficial and
efficient use of their land thereby
allowing title to pass to the individual
taking care of the land from the holder
that has effectively abandoned it today
the primary justification for adverse
possession is to incentivize landowners
to settle title disputes by putting
statutes of limitations on possible
litigation and possession in other words
if we don't really know who owns the
land it's a good idea to give clean
title to someone who has had the land
for a very long time and often made
improvements to it it removes a cloud of
title so to summarize i am not telling
you all to commit years of criminal
trespass to maybe acquire real property
but if you've already been committing
criminal trespass for decades at the
very least now you can find out if you
accidentally have acquired that real
property so good for you now what if i
told you you could watch another legal
eagle video but this time it's on the
rights you definitely want to exercise
all the time well this full-length
companion video exists and is
exclusively on nebula because sadly if i
put it on youtube it would probably get
demonetized and there's no way that
you'd ever be able to see it but nebula
is different as you've probably heard by
now nebula is home to tons of exclusive
and ad-free content like my first full
length documentary bad law words good my
long extended interview with mark rober
and tons tons more all of this exclusive
content is only on nebula which you can
get for free with curiosity stream of
course the reason all these videos are
exclusively on nebula is because they
probably wouldn't work on youtube
because of the way that the site works
on the other hand nebula is a different
platform without an algorithm and
without any ads because nebula is a
place where we can experiment with
content and put things on there that we
couldn't put on youtube it's just a
platform with great and unique content
that's made by independent educational
creators ones you probably already know
like tom scott thomas frank and thomas
flight as well as lots of other people
not named tom like lindsey ellis real
engineering wendover productions and
many others there's new exclusive
content released almost every day in
fact nebula is creator-owned and creator
operated and by the way we've been
developing nebula like crazy nebula now
has apps for ios android apple tv roku
fire tv and android tv and by fellow
creators and i really care about nebula
so we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiositystream because they're the
go-to source for the best documentaries
and long-form educational content on the
internet they even have an entire
section devoted to unsolved mysteries
and crime so if you like my videos
you'll love the stuff on curiosity
stream now the best way to get access to
nebula and all of this incredible
content is definitely through the
amazing curiosity stream nebula bundle
deal and with its current sales price
it's less than 15 a year to get full
access to both sites and to be clear
that nebulous subscription is not a
trial it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member i genuinely
don't know a better deal anywhere where
you'll get two streaming sites both with
content you'll actually watch and enjoy
all for less than 15 a year at the
current sales price but what's more
signing up will actually help countless
independent educational creators beyond
just legal eagle so be sure to get this
bundle deal by clicking on the button
that's right here on screen right now
which will take you directly to
curiositystream.com
legaleagle where you can sign up or you
can click on the link that's down below
in the description it's a great way to
support educational content and get tons
of exclusive content which you should go
watch right now or you can click on this
playlist over here with all my other
educational videos so click here or i'll
see you in court